I think that the the Academy isn't isn't
it very has put themselves into into a
very uncomfortable position and they
deserve all of the discomfort that
they're experiencing but and and you
know the question of the broadcast
itself is an interesting one because
Chris Rock as host and of course he was
he was put in place as host before the
nominations came out and before the the
protests against them no matter what he
does and I'm sure his his his jokes will
be very pointed and very honest and very
strong because that's that's the kind of
comedian kind of performer he is
nonetheless it can't help but be a kind
of window dressing or sort of
compensation well see you know yeah we
didn't nominate any any black people but
but our host is african-american so so
it's all it's all fine right where we're
all good but I I think that the one
thing that that Chris Rock will
inevitably do I don't think he will or
can or would want to dispel this
controversy but in a way to focus it and
because the the the real matter is not
just the Academy in the Academy's
membership and and the and the voting
and nominating rules that's all an
important local issue but the
controversy over the over the Oscars of
the Oscars so white I idea is has much
more to do with with with the film
industry which have with how it's
structured with what movies get made
with what kind of opportunities are
available to to two different people
with with the fact that the power in the
film industry resides with with with
white man whose whose perspective it's
not that that any of them are
individually necessarily racist or
bigoted but there's a collective myopia
that comes in and so and and and I think
an an unconscious bias where you know
you're you're a middle-aged white guy
and you see a young white guy and you're
like oh yeah let's give that
to break and there are and there are
women and there are people of color who
are we're just as talented whose work
can be just as strong but you don't you
don't see them and and that's that's a
very big problem and that's a problem
that I think that it is nothing but good
news that that problem is now being
talked about being aired out in public
being becoming an issue of controversy
and discussion